j'ai été conçu pour sauver le monde
les humains contempler le ciel ils
voyaient de l'espoir c'est la première
chose que je leur enlèverait ya qu un
chemin vers la paix leur extinction
j'avais seulement l'intention de
protéger le monde
j'ai créé quelque chose de monstrueux
l'intelligence artificielle
ça s'appelle le programme ultra
j'en ai assez de voir des innocents
payer pour nos erreurs
c'est pas pour ça que nous par pour
mettre fin à la guerre et rentrer chez
nous
eh ben c'est une méga défaite
voilà réunis
sans rien d'autre que notre esprit et
notre volonté de sauver le monde
alors en avant des battez vous
centerra sûrement pas tous je n'ai rien
de prévu demain soir
toujours que je repasse derrière vous
les gars
nous pouvons les détruire
de l'intérieur
vraiment tu es le meilleur
l'oreille de terre